it looks like the big threat to westeros
in game of thrones season 7
are the others or white walkers with
their army of the dead
marching on the wall to bring a night
that never
ends these guys are a problem cause the
walkers are not only super strong super
angry ice demons but their swords can
shatter steel they seem immune to normal
weapons
there are just two known ways to kill a
walker
one is with a blade of dragonglass go
watch that video
and the other way is with a blade of
valyrian steel
we see this in season 5 and it's also
hinted in the books
valyrian steel is a special kind of
metal used to make swords that are
sharper stronger and lighter than blades
of regular steel
the steel was made in valyria hundreds
of years ago but when valyria was
destroyed in a mysterious doom
the secret of making valyrian steel was
lost
so the valyrian blades that remain are
really valuable
there are a couple hundred of them in
westeros but only about 20 are mentioned
in the books most are the treasured
heirlooms of noble houses
handed from generation to generation
through the centuries
lots of these swords have great
backstories and histories and some of
them may play a role in the war with the
walkers to come
so let's have a look at the valyrian
blades of game of thrones
probably the most obvious valyrian sword
is longclaw the sword used by jon snow
longclaw is a bastard sword which means
it's a bit longer than a normal
longsword
it's also pretty fitting given that jon
is a bastard
or he's believed to be a bastard but
that's another story
longclaw is given to john by joe mormot
whose family held the sword for hundreds
of years
jor originally gave lonclaw to his son
jorah
but jorah dishonoured the family by
selling slaves and fleeing westeros
he leaves the sword behind though so joe
gives it to jon
it would be interesting to see jorah's
reaction if he ever sees jon with his
family's sword
but with its bastard blade and white
wolf pommel longclaw
is very symbolic of jon's identity it'll
no doubt play a big role in jon's fight
against the white walkers
and the sword might even tie into the
prophecies about a hero
called azor is expected to lead the
fight against the walkers with a flaming
sword
called lightbringer that's what stannis
and melisandre try to emulate
there are theories suggesting that jon
sword longclaw might somehow become the
true lightbringer to be the fire
and the light needed to face the
darkness and cold
another sword that appears in the show
is heartsbane
the valyrian steel greatsword of house
tarly
randall tarly makes a big deal of how he
doesn't want his fat
cowardly son sam to inherit the fabled
blade heartsbane
which is part of the reason why randall
forces sam to join the night's watch
hotspain has a long history a few
hundred years ago
an outlaw from dawn called the vulture
king was stopped when
men led by a savage samtarli hunted him
down
using heartspain to slay dozens of
dornishmen
there's a pretty good chance alsam was
named after this historical savage sam
now in the books heartspain is held by
randall tarly who's known as one of the
great soldiers of westeros
but in the show sam visits home and
takes heartsbane from randall
bringing it with him to the citadel the
sort of hogwartsy
university of the maesters which could
play out in some interesting ways
maybe sam and the maesters could study
heart spain
try to unlock the secrets of valyrian
steel or maybe find more valyrian blades
but whatever happens at the citadel
randall will want his sword back
another important sword is ice the
valyrian steel greatsword of house stark
ice is really big apparently too big to
use in battle
it's more of a ceremonial sword ned
stark uses it to execute garrett at the
start of book 1
and near the end of book 1 illin payne
uses it to execute ned
so the lannisters end up with ice and
tywin lannister decides to melt ice down
and reforge it into two smaller swords
because while no one knows how to make
new valyrian steel some skilled smiths
can reforge it into new forms
in this case tywin hires the armorer
tobo mott
who happens to be the teacher of gendry
so some people speculate that gendry
knows a thing or two about valyrian
steel
but yeah ice is melted down and forged
into two smaller swords
tywin gives one to his son jaime and the
other to his grandson
joffrey joffrey names his sword widow's
whale
because he's a nasty little [ __ ] while
jaime does something more meaningful
jaime names his sword oathkeeper and
gives it to brienne
because remember jaime swears an oath to
catelyn stark that in return for being
set free
jaime would return to her sansa and arya
so jaime gives brienne oathkeeper to
uphold this oath on his behalf
to defend ned stark's daughter with ned
stark's own steel
the sword also represents the respect
jaime has for brienne
he used to have nothing but contempt for
her but now he gives her
a sword fit for a hero joffrey meanwhile
uses his valyrian sword to slay
a book and then a pie and then he dies
the sword then presumably goes to joff's
brother tommen though in the show
tommen's dead too so it's not clear
who'll use widow's whale next
widow's whale is now the only known
valyrian sword in the city of king's
landing
so it surely will come in handy sometime
so those are the major valyrian swords
that appear in the story but there are
also some interesting historical ones
perhaps the most famous valyrian blade
is blackfire
blackfyre was the sword of king aegon
targaryen
the conqueror who first took over
westeros aegon was a great warrior and
used blackfyre in the battles that
founded the targaryen dynasty
each king after aegon bore his sword so
blackfire became an important symbol of
targaryen political legitimacy
if you had the sword you were seen as
the rightful
king that's why it was so shocking when
king aegon iv
one of the worst targaryen kings gave
blackfyre to one of his bastard sons
daemon
daemon took blackfyre as his house name
and later claimed to be the rightful
king
beginning a war for succession called
the first blackfyre rebellion
the great battle of this rebellion was
at the red grass field where daemon used
blackfyre in a jewel against gwayne
corbrey who had his own famous valyrian
blade called lady forlorn
it's said they fought for near an hour
and each time blackfyre and lady forlorn
clashed you could hear the sound from
leagues away
half a song and half a scream eventually
daemon won the jewel but then he was
killed by arrows from his half-brother
bloodraven who by the way
is the same guy who later becomes a tree
god and teaches bran how to magic
more on him later so daemon died on the
red grass field but his blackfyre
ancestors continued to rebel against the
targaryens for years
and all of this began partly because
aegon iv
gave the conqueror a sword to his
bastard son
the sword represents being the rightful
king
but for the last hundred years or so no
one seems to know
where the sword is which could have
implications
for the schemes of varys and illyrio in
the books
varys and illyrio have this crazy
complex conspiracy to put a kid called
young
griff who they say is aegon vi
on the iron throne go watch that video
but
basically there's evidence that this
aegon kid might actually be
a blackfyre a descendant of daemon so
it's very interesting that in a reading
by george martin of a draft version of a
chapter from dance
illyrio mentions a gift for young griff
and
a sword and things griff must know
fans speculate that illyrio may have
blackfyre the fabled blade of aegon
and will give it to griff to grant him
political legitimacy as a king
this is very speculative but it could
make a lot of sense
it'd solve the mystery of what happened
to blackfyre and would tie
present plots to the past in a really
cool way
so yeah blackfyre is important and
ladyforlorn is also a thing
after the duel at the redgrass field the
sword returned to house corbre
and a hundred years later lynne corbrey
used it in robert's rebellion
killing prince louis martell of the
kingsguard lin
is now involved in the plots in the vale
working with littlefinger but it's not
clear if he can be trusted
lin's a dangerous man violent and
possibly a pedophile depending on how
you interpret this line about
boys but yeah that's what's happening
with lady forlorn now
historically there was also a sword
called lady forlorn used in the wars of
the andals in the vale
but apparently that may have been a
different lady for lorne
people keep naming swords after famous
older swords which can
confuse things but anyway another
important targaryen sword
is called dark sister while aegon the
conqueror had blackfire his sister queen
visenya had dark sister
a slender blade designed for a female
warrior
visenya used the sword during aegon's
conquest when she wasn't roasting people
with her dragon
many years later dark sister went to
daemon targaryen the rogue prince who
used the sword during the dance of the
dragons the big targaryen civil war
during a mid-air dragon battle with his
nephew aymond onei
daemon leapt from his dragon onto
aemon's dragon
and drove dark sister through aemon's
one good eye before both men and their
dragons fell from the sky
and died this is why we need a game of
thrones prequel movie guys
after daemon dark sister went to aemon
targaryen the famous dragon knight said
to be one of the greatest and noblest
knights that ever lived
he's also the namesake of maester aemon
targaryen
after the dragon night dark sister went
to a man called brynden rivers
or bloodraven bloodraven really needs
his own video but basically he was a
king's bastard
a spymaster sorcerer hand of the king he
killed damon blackfire at the red grass
field had a relationship with sierra sea
star who might possibly be quaithe
then bloodraven joined the night's watch
became lord commander went north
and finally became a tree wizard man the
guy who's known in the show
as the three-eyed raven but the question
here is
what happened to the sword dark sister
did bloodraven bring it with him to the
night's watch like
joel mormont did and if he did is the
sword now in the cave
where bloodraven trains bran if so it
seems possible that bran's friend mira
might
take up the sword it is designed for a
woman's hand after all
in fact some people think that in the
show she already has dark sister
she does grab a sword from the cave in
season six
another possibility is for dark sister
to go to arya
needle is cool and all but surely a
ninja assassin like arya should have a
storied valyrian sword like dark sister
and arya is herself kind of a dark
sister
this is all wild speculation but given
the history and importance of dark
sister
it seems likely that the sword will
reappear in the story
another lost valyrian sword is bright
raw
house lannister bought bright raw for a
huge amount of gold before the doom of
valyria
but a hundred years later after valyria
was destroyed
king tommen lannister went on an
expedition to plunder its ruins
he took brightroar with him and never
returned
house lannister lost one of its most
valuable treasures which always
frustrated tywin when he led house
lannister
so at one point tywin's younger brother
gerion went on a quest to find bright
raw but he never returned
either go watch the garion video but in
the end
tywin got his valyrian sword in the form
of ice which he made into oath keeper
and widow's whale
in the books by the way these swords are
coloured red
tywin has the metal sort of dyed to her
rippling lannister crimson color
because tywin's all about that house
pride family legacy stuff
anyway the next couple of swords are
owned by ironborn
there's red rain and nightfall
red rain is a valyrian sword held by
dunstan drum
the lord of old wick he whips it out at
the king's moot and recounts how his
ancestor hilmardrum the cunning
famously took red rain from some night
armed only with his wits and a cudgel
and there's a theory that the knight who
drum took red rain from might have been
from house rain
a family in the westerlands who tywin
lannister wiped out
the rains have a red lion for their
sigil and their name is rain
so red rain is a fitting name in more
ways than one
and the westerlands have historically
been raided by ironborn so it makes a
lot of sense for the drums to have taken
red rain from the reigns
in book 4 drum is on raids with red rain
in the reach
nightfall is a valyrian sword held by
the knight sir harris harlow
harris supports asher or yara greyjoy at
the kingsmoot
though euron later kind of steals him
from her by making harris a lord
the sword nightfall was historically
wielded by the infamous ironborn raider
dalton greyjoy called the red kraken for
all the blood he shared
it said dalton loved three things the
sea
women and his valyrian sword nightfall
it's not clear how red rain and
nightfall will tie into the broader
story of thrones but
some speculate that king euron might
take these swords from their owners
in the books euron has a set of armor
made of valyrian steel
he might want to compliment that with a
valyrian sword or two
a nightfall is a pretty appropriate name
for someone who is low-key trying to
cause a lovecraftian blood magic
apocalypse type situation which
he is in the books we'll have to explain
that in
another video but basically euron is
scary another valyrian blade that's had
a big impact on the story
is not another sword but a knife
in book and season 1 an assassin tries
to kill bran stark with a knife of
valyrian steel
catlin takes the blade to king's landing
and littlefinger tells her the knife is
tyrion's
so catelyn thinking the dwarf tried to
kill her son arrests tyrion which kicks
off the war of the five kings
the thing is the real culprit behind the
cat spore is joffrey
littlefinger lied about the knife in a
deliberate attempt to cause war
after betraying ned stark and profiting
off the downfall of his family
littlefinger carries the valyrian knife
in later books shamelessly wearing a
symbol
of his lies and betrayal now in the
books
sansa is in the veil with littlefinger
and the knife
some people speculate that sansa will
use the knife to kill him
destroying littlefinger with the same
blade he used to destroy her family
there'd be a great poetry to that though
things will probably go differently in
the show
there are a few more valyrian swords
that were used in the dance of the
dragons
the targaryen civil war from a hundred
years ago
lamentation is a sword carried by a guy
called willem royce
he got caught up in the storming of the
dragon pit when a rioting mob of common
folk
killed some chained up dragons in all
the violence and the chaos
willem royce and his sword were lost
there was also bald john roxton
and ormund hightower who bore the
sword's orphan maker
and vigilance roxton was killed and we
haven't heard from his family since but
the hightowers are still around so they
might have vigilance at old town
where euron may be closing in there are
a few more valyrian blades that are
only briefly mentioned in the text some
soldier from lease had a valyrian sword
called
truth the celtics of chloride are said
to have a valyrian steel axe
and a guy called kago has a valyrian
steel iraq
one of those curvy dothraki scythey
things which is apparently pretty rare
in valyrian steel
okago is a captain of the windblown
mercenaries so he'll be involved in the
story ahead in slaver's bay
finally there are a bunch of valyrian
daggers among the treasure euron
presents at the kingsmoot
it's a little weird the way these are
just offhandedly mentioned
as though a bunch of valyrian blades is
like no big deal
maybe valyrian daggers are more common
than the swords are but you'd think that
if so
someone like tywin could just buy a
bunch of valyrian daggers and reforge
them into the sword tywin desperately
wanted for so long
so the true value and rarity of lyrian
steel is not very clear
but regardless this is every valyrian
blade mentioned in all of game of
thrones
longclaw and heartspain ice oath keeper
and widow's whale blackfyre dark sister
lady for lawn
bright raw red rain and nightfall the
swords of the dance littlefinger's
dagger and this
other miscellaneous stuff too there are
more swords out there of course
about 180 more apparently and westeros
might need them all
to win the war against the walkers
thanks for watching if you want to learn
more about the histories and backstories
of thrones
you might like to read the world of ice
and fire george martin's world book
which is all about this sort of stuff
there's a link to buy it below which
supports this channel at no extra cost
to you
some of this art is from the world of
ice and fire while other pieces are by a
mock and catherine
check out the description for details
thanks to the translators for
translating captions and thanks also to
the patrons for making alt-shift x
possible
including james beagles yelda aktuna
avery calvert rufus t
firefly shuiko shining force 2 and hodor
targaryen
cheers